antes de degradarse a tormenta tropical
eta de este hecho cientos de casas
inundó decenas de calles y obligó a
evacuar a miles de familias sólo en
honduras las intensas lluvias han
provocado cuantiosos destrozos como
arrojado una vez 1700 personas están
siendo distribuidas en los diferentes
centros de atención establecidos por
nuestras autoridades y también estamos
preparando algunas fuerzas los 35 mil
hombres de las fuerzas armadas de
diferentes unidades para poder ayudar a
toda esta población una vez que las
aguas hayan bajado el presidente de
guatemala indicó que en su país el
balance de afectados supera los 75 mil y
en nicaragua los organismos de atención
de emergencias alertaron sobre el
desbordamiento de varios ríos y
afectaciones en los municipios de
somotillo y corinto en panamá las
lluvias azotaron principalmente la
provincia de chiriquí y en mexico el
sistema de protección civil reportó la
afectación de más de 80 mil ciudadanos
ante la catástrofe la comunidad de
estados latinoamericanos y caribeños
celac solicitó la inclusión del país en
la petición de asistencia internacional
a causa de los efectos del fenómeno las
5 de la mañana más 1 de acá porque ya ni
donde nos vemos es que todavía adentro
también está oyendo completamente mis
cosas tomadas se espera que en el
transcurso de la jornada eta avance en
dirección a cuba y las islas caimán por
lo que las instituciones de prevención
de desastres han activado los protocolos
de atención